so you probably heard that all the adage
that every person has at least one good
book in them I believe in something
grander than that I believe that every
great person has at least one great beer
all they need is a fearless brewer like
me to coax it out welcome
so that's odd let's drink it so you
might already know that Chris Bosh is a
ten-time and VA is a two-time NBA
champion and proud Texas but you
probably don't know that he's also an
avid home brewer and globe-trotting
foodie who every offseason goes out
around the world with his family to
check out great beer and food spots so
today we're here in beautiful LA to do a
one-of-a-kind brew with Chris it's not
going to be your normal basement we're
gonna do this brute style
Chris Bosh what's going on how are you
good chat on the phone with your shader
good to see you I'm excited for that you
excited - all right so game plan we are
going to explore the fine city of LA
based on what you told me you like to
make for beers and what you like to
drink and based on your Texas roots we
are going to put some food awesome Texas
barbecue even better and we're gonna
ride this that's cool
you're gonna plenty of legroom and we're
literally gonna brew while we go that's
awesome you're a grown man brewing you
got what are you bringing and I brought
my cup you got the cups I got the cold
beer let's do this
today we're on a search for some special
ingredients that will help us create a
beer that not only reflects Chris's
Texas roots but also is passion for
traveling to exotic locations around the
globe
you got breweries in your house in
Florida yeah and you get a brewery here
your house you know yes and what are you
doing all grain you're doing partial
grain I have an all grain system here in
LA but at Miami I do extra extra at last
time yeah save like - oh yeah I have a
lot less time to work with
even if I do get to squeeze the brew day
and I've got to make way too long yeah
absolutely now like me Chris is no
rookie when it comes to brewing but it's
something neither of us have done in the
back of the limo so this system unlike
the ones you have in LH and down Miami
this thing's all self-contained
automated this little puppy's called the
peak of brewing cymatic cool whole thing
brewing in the limo so we're going to do
we're going back to the dark beer on
today's bro this one will be a stout so
similar to our chance yeah I've loaded
pretty much everything except want you
to actually help through the ad here
okay Rhys malty
smell that guess what wood that's fired
over I mean I get my stuff somewhere
where you think some from your favorite
cuisine musky would you're just gonna
add that the rest of the grain it's
gonna make it great isn't it
yeah that's the secret sauce I've added
the first two hop additions the last two
trays are kind of what we're doing our
scavenger hunt for okay let's find like
a spice that you you that both of us
think are gonna go well with the
mesquite and the dark grains smells
awesome
then that's smell nice I always love
that smell so whatever we make today
what do you think like December ish
we'll do a bigger batch up at dogfish
and I'll bring it down a little sir
that'd be awesome when we have you rid
of it so you brought the cups okay
here's one from your home
these guys well of course boom our
friends is Funky Buddha or this is like
going to be a pretty intense matul
now look for a ton of it maybe it's
about eleven ABB serial style images
yeah but with wood shot funky booty
beers have you had the Floridian of
course that's like the most popular we
did yeah of course the maple bacon
that's one of the ones in order chair
sex be brutal with your neck 62 miles an
hour the things you can do with the
darker beers it's I think they're more
flexible yeah more nuanced yeah but your
opportunities for complexity yeah pretty
bra absolutely I mean you can have a
smoky you can do sweet its chocolate
I've had some chocolate ones chocolate
porters and stouts that aren't sweet at
all yeah just what I'm on right now I'm
sure after a little while I'll probably
be on to something else trying to your
style what yeah yes I was absolutely are
you gonna get this anymore that beer
systems reading systems in we're
gnashing good all right so boom this is
it world flavors blood since but you
first pays before beauty
I smoked some local years let's go down
again
hell yeah I don't think I've ever had no
no thank you very much thank you -
Cheers
ah - babe you Kevin
okay I'm ready what should I say a
little sand or a bush maybe you guys I
got some things to go Stevie alright
what's up with you oh good I'm here for
barbecue you got a welcome home man all
right after my spot we gonna get on with
you Texas - so what do you think of the
if you're gonna if you have blood cells
what would you do for the lineup of food
what you tell us is going to inspire our
beer recipe - okay we all live on your
parking lot right now we got we're in
the mash cycle we're brewing in the limo
so way to make you tell me y'all
bootlegging in my Park so we may be
taking some things from what we learned
from what you're doing with your food
spice wise Sugar's wise and
incorporating into the brew that we're
doing in your parcel we gonna have a
fabric union I'm gonna move it then
you'll just do it
cv already get it
whoa
it's how we do a blessing when I got a
phone got your poor I really betting so
Texas nail hardening spoke a little
place they got a got a real nice kick
tool and we got you some fifteen hour
smoked brisket man all right oh my god
it's so good like butter I'm trying to
go
I'm trying to go what's places on
getting here would you mind bringing out
some of your most like proprietary
spices that are known for and maybe
Chris and I can add some think about
them in the brew as I'm gonna maybe we
bring out our Robin our our brisket bro
point sounds good yeah I think that'll
be good the smokiness the brown sugar
with the Conte I don't add a little
maple II thing and then we got the
mesquite yeah all right Thank You Kenny
you're good at what you do yeah success
thanks a lot man thank you with his love
of barbecue and his Texas roots now
officially represented in our beer we
make a quick stop at a local spice store
to pick up some flavors that tap into
Christmas love a Globetrotter yeah
that's too much clothes clothing yeah
this is Cayenne
it works yeah
I bless you thank you how are you not
sneezing
well good new la limos not a powder but
new spice powders guys we will never
know exactly what's in Kevin's abyss of
Awesomeness
yeah oh we never will know scared yeah
but that's of our spices that I'll be
the forefront and then if we go that way
what's the lineup we've got Cayenne uh
we've got allspice I don't really know
what that is when I could have special
up we're not gonna crush this up knows
where it goes a lot more intense yeah
got tumeric and a little bit of cinnamon
yeah yeah I like what we've done you I
think so all right so we're gonna do
four of these we might be messing up and
I'm sure we're not it doesn't it feel
good to take Oh
the craziest beer I've ever heard
you know Gavin okay now we wheeze
the stout recipe we've concocted today
will be used through a bigger batch back
at dogfish am but it must first pass a
test as old as brewing itself tasting of
the wort all right Chris this is it it's
the best tasting word I've ever had one
more thing what's the name of this beer
the only thing I can think of my
granddad I named my son after him his
name was daddy Jack daddy Jack style Oh
like a sounds like a old hard man from
Texas the old school guy look I'm kids
you guy out there yeah that's a nice
size right I'll pick you go to you kids
also will be What's Up kiddo
Jack hey guys it was right because we
have put all right bag summon Oh bye
alright we're coming crazy day Chris
Bosh and met his son baby Jack we brewed
daddy Jack amazing spices amazing beers
this is going to be a good one's gonna
be odd but I'm gonna drink it
you
you